jim mcgovern from massachusetts nice to
meet you thank you yeah
i'll see you again
yes you're welcome
jason
nice to meet you adam shift from
california you're welcome
thank you
we believe that we are visiting you
uh to say thank you
uh for your fight for freedom that we
are on a frontier of freedom and that
your fight is a fight for everyone
and so our commitment is to be there for
you until the fight is done i'm very
honored to be with a very distinguished
congressional delegation that has
traveled here to send a clear message to
the world america stands with ukraine
we stand with ukraine until victory is
won do not be bullied by bullies
if they making threats you cannot back
down
that's my view of it that you you we're
there for the fight
and you cannot uh you cannot
fold to a bully we're in the process of
something stronger than len lee's right
now we are not lending or leasing we are
giving support in a very strong way and
the len lease will not just be for
ukraine but also for eastern european
countries who are assisting so it will
be
as neat as we see where it would be most
effective but we will be ready the
president
bestowed upon me
decorated me with the order of oha the
duchess of the third degree
i accept this on behalf of the
congressional democrats uh it was a
surprise but i think it was a reflection
of his appreciation for what the
congress has brought to the table we're
talking about sanctions and yes
we're going to increase some and we're
going to bring it together not just one
nation
but all of us collectively and we will
review and that's what we talked about
also what so thus far have been
successful and what we need to do
to put more pressure on them so nothing
is going to decrease
everything is going to increase pressure
from the outside pressure from the
inside there is nowhere for him to go
we're going to continue to he putin
surrenders
if he does anything
in regards
to unconventional weapons
dealing with
uh anything like chemical weapons
or any kind of strategical nukes
all bets are off the speaker just said
it we're not going to back down to a
bully
he's not going to be able to you know
sometimes bullies keep talking
but if they cross
he's going to know he's going to have to
face the consequences he needs to know
that so there's no back
sliding or backing up that's not going
to divide us
it will only bring us closer together to
make sure that we repudiate him and stop
his aggression